it's time for our top photos of the day
we have a scoured the photos and found
you some three beautiful ones the top
one on Friday the heat index or the
quote feels like temperature yeah at the
machchar Airport in southern Iran
reached get this a brutal 165 degrees
it's 165 that's the second highest ever
recorded 178 degrees I don't want to get
into the climate change debate I do
gives me pause I do that it's a second
highest ever recorded
well I'm by that over the weekend it was
118 Abu Dhabi 113 Kuwait City 111 these
are anecdotal things that get our
attention but the broader actual
empirical data about what's going on all
over the world is unimpeachable it is it
is obvious and terrifying and clear here
and more so than three years ago more so
than three years ago this is what's
actually completely terrifying is that
is that the things that we had predicted
would take decades are taking years
that's scary next photo all right number
two Friday night's blue moon wasn't blue
but people across the world oval of the
lunar rarity a blue moon occurs when two
full moons rise in one month the event
is quite uncommon the next double
feature won't be until 2018 the last was
in 2012 I felt they all took place in
Kentucky oh no I went to I went to awake
this weekend and there was a brass band
on the beach underneath the blue moon
and I think it was it was it was it was
gorgeous absolutely beautiful
well there is a that's not going to
leave my head this morning
all right top photo number one top photo
Saturday night in Manhattan images of
endangered species including precess
Hawaiian were projected onto the Empire
State Building to raise awareness along
with sessile a tiger and eagle and a
whale were all illustrated in lights the
images covered 33 floors of the building
and could be seen for miles and they
could be seen for miles on Facebook the
next day to a charismatic macro
megafauna I
that's how we say that's how we saved
the world through charismatic megafauna
I mean I wonder where we are in this
debate julian robertson has joined us
some time to time a legendary investor
and he and his family have been out
front on what decades ahead on Tigers
mr. Robertson would say is well yeah
there was a debate we had and now
there's this amazing new urgency about
wildlife in general got something simple
like honeybees yes
yeah just very simple right in our
backyards were there great photos today
to get us started on that we